[Music]
you're listening to anxiety with Michael
Rosenbaum Ryan Michael I always say that
Ryan Michael good to see you made it
back yep how are you I forgot about ads
and we had to do ads today yeah I was
like kind of like uh I woke up on the
wrong side of the bed that's because I
had a Taffy you've also got a large
Band-Aid on your knee yeah softball man
I made a major league caliber play yeah
did you get him out I'm not kidding like
yeah I'm gonna toot my own horn there
for a second my uh the guys were just
like dude because I heard them talking
about the play when I was sitting on the
other side of the bench like dude that
play was like and I was like yes
I mean I
I made a couple nice plays I hadn't
played in a while and it was uh we won
by a run and they had the bases loaded
at the end and here's what happened I
turned this double play to end the game
but they called him safe and we ended up
they scored five more runs and we barely
won in that last inning and afterwards I
said to them because it was my bad dude
I feel bad but you guys won so I was
like oh I admitted it he admitted it we
need computers oh man yeah and I uh I
picked it I was uh you know for sagging
after I went to went to Paramount and uh
did that um so that felt good seeing my
other colleagues and people you know
fighting for something that is is
important and yeah yeah and you know I
think it's like I'm not gonna get into
it but I think the rest of the world
kind of views it as oh poor actors they
don't make enough money and the fact is
that 99 of actors don't even make twenty
five thousand fifty thousand dollars a
year no I know and there's there's more
stories coming out now but like you know
what people are actually getting paid
yeah
imagine guys like Netflix you don't get
residuals no buyouts and so it's a lot
of stuff so I just just get educated on
it if you don't know about it and I
certainly have educated myself on it a
little bit because uh it's you know but
it happens all over the world I mean
people working for these large
conglomerates that um are getting
treated like [__] paid like [__] and
people are making billions the top make
billions and I always came you know
thought of the idea that you know if
you're making money and someone's an
integral part of your
Empire or whatever reward them call them
it's it's just human nature and uh I
just don't know what people need with a
hundred billion dollars or even 10
million dollars uh you know if you're
making a lot of money it's like uh you
know share the wealth share the wealth
man it's it's by the way your employees
are going to work harder for you they're
going to let things feel that they're
respected
um and um this is something where the
rich get richer and you know
um
it happens all around the world it's not
just with the Hollywood driving down
Sunset there's a bunch of hotel workers
are on strike
well good yeah I hope they win yeah
because again what are they getting paid
I know I mean if if somebody profits a
hundred billion dollars a year or 50
million dollars a year it says hey we
profited 50 million how about I keep 40
and take that 10 million and give it to
everybody else he's been working so hard
and the planet's still on Fire come on
man it's on fire enough about enough I
thought about striking but I got nothing
to I could I could pick at this but
that's really it yeah what no why don't
you go with me one day I got nothing to
strike why don't you go with me don't
you have to be part of the unions that's
gonna stop you from [__] walking with
me probably not no I'm gonna bring you a
sandwich one day I'll bring you a
sandwich
uh thanks for listening great guests
today
um and I encourage you guys if you like
this interview
um please stick around and uh subscribe
to the show write a review it really
helps the show we've been doing this for
years and we just started doing better
um and that's because of the the great
team I have around me and
um boy four years of just why am I doing
this other than just I love the podcast
but
um now it seems like this is this has
been a pretty good year and I'm grateful
and
um thank you Westwood one thank you
Bryce thank you Jason thank you Ryan and
uh
you know it's just it's just
it seems like we're actually going up a
little you know it's we're not
at a plateau we're not going down we're
going up a little we're not skyrocketing
by any means but we're going up the
projectoring so that's good
um also
if you want to visit the inside of you
online store we've got so much cool
merch I just got the new inside of you
zip up jackets they're freaking dope and
those are selling really well
um Sun spin my band is uh playing
Saturday at 5 PM Pacific Standard Time
virtually just go to sunspin.com get a
ticket if you want to support the band
if you haven't come it's a lot of fun
it's prizes it's uh
should we give you shout outs we have
the big screen up so I see all your
names and your comments and we we're
playing and we say oh look it's
Milwaukee John what's up dude and
there's prizes and zooms and and you
really support the band and we're trying
to do another album so thank you you can
also go to stageit.com
s-t-a-g-e-i-t.com type in sunspin and
get tickets 5 PM Pacific Standard time
um Talk Ville I know you guys I don't
really need to promote that you guys
know where that is inside of you podcast
or a
talkfillpodcast.com uh you can get some
sign stuff from me and Tom uh Patron
I'll never forget uh patreon.com
inside of you and to help the podcast
continue to stay afloat without the
patrons uh we couldn't do the podcast
and that's that's
the biggest part of what I was telling
you in the beginning that we're doing
better because you know
of these guys uh the handles Ryan why
don't you give us the handles uh inside
of you pod on Twitter anxiety podcast on
Instagram and Facebook oh also I'll be
I'm on the Cameo but I'll be uh at
conventions uh Tom and I will be in
Rhode Island in September DC Salt Lake
City
um so get tickets to that we do an
evening with Michael and Tom and that's
a blast we should be doing those events
so make sure you look for those tickets
on Friday or Saturday nights I think
they are
um that's about it for all that jazz uh
my dog isn't pissing and [__] in the
house as much so that's good but you
have to be on top of them yeah I mean
not on physically on top of them but you
have to be on top of it you have to let
him out still constantly and it's but
he's uh I love the little bastard but
he's he's a challenge he is a challenge
uh Rachel Bilson
she's got these podcasts she's got a
great body of work
and
she was adorable Rachel if you're even
listening to this which you're probably
not adorable she was she's so smart and
and fun and light and she's got a great
podcast broad ideas that you have to
listen to and it's a lot of fun
and uh she's a great guest
so why don't we just get into it why
don't we just talk to and get inside of
Rachel Bilson it's my point of view
listening to inside of you
th
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode and any we
air before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
do you think
coffee
is a date okay my favorite movie of all
time is called just friends have you
seen it no okay is that Ryan Reynolds
yes it is all right and in the movie if
you go out to lunch let's say it's a day
date they're like a day date that's
friends
according to this movie okay
I mean I feel like there's room there it
could be a date but I think coffee
is a introduction
thank you
I see that too so you don't need to have
a response back to them after the coffee
if you don't want to you just you don't
have to go oh this was great you know I
mean I don't want to respond to people
after like sleeping with them the first
night so I'm just kidding Christ on his
throne no uh I'm just funny I'm just
funny I think that
I don't like calling anybody back ever
so what you know it's like the Irish
goodbye but like I do the Irish goodbye
for sure absolutely I'm at something I'm
saying happy birthday doing whatever
yeah and after that and they started I
start to just you just like yeah you
just slip on out yeah you don't need to
say goodbye to everybody no oh my God
that is like my biggest I don't like it
and I don't like the awkward like do I
hug you goodbye like do I have to like
you're like Seinfeld now hug you is this
uh well Larry David is the love of me is
this the last time I'm gonna see him
yeah are we friends what is this I do a
lot like that I have my own I do too I
think we all have that little Seinfeld
in US of course it's just who actually
is vocal about it yeah right so I I
can't believe how like I never have I
ever met you I don't know I you always
do the safe thing like oh it's so good
to see you and then it covers it that's
what you said to me when I showed up and
in my head I'm like [__] have I met him
no I meant it's so good to see you right
like yeah and again
just to see that is like a fair thing to
do yeah especially in this business and
you meet a ton of people and you see
people it's a safe way it was really
nice to see you nice to see you
I I think you're right I think that's
important I'm usually right yeah are you
yeah are you usually right yeah do you
admit when you're wrong yes it's
accountability is a big thing I just
talked about this but yeah it's
important to be able to admit when
you're wrong really and how do you go
about it does it take a minute or do you
immediately you know what it depends on
who I'm wrong it depends on who I'm
wrong to
uh it's a powerful thing though it's a
powerful thing it's an accountability
well when you can look at somebody and
say
um you know what
my bad let's let's move on that's on me
yeah my bad and even if it's not on you
and you take it that pisses people off
oh if you're dating someone you know
what it's my fault let's
pass is that passive aggressive yeah 100
it is so yeah I shouldn't do that no
it's a dick move you can't there's a
dick move but I just don't want to get
in there it's like condescending it's
like you know no you're right like but
if you yeah you can't do it there's so
much like you know I I talked to Rob to
who you brought along today Rob Hollis
who started this whole thing with me
years ago and then he left me for Dax
Shepard but it's happened before yeah
yeah but I told him I said this is a
good career move he knows a lot bigger
celebrities and you know he knows he has
more money uh you know uh you'll be in
your Kristen Bell you should do this
it's better and of course now he's a
millionaire so you know this is the
right move so really you helped him are
you like a finders fee yeah uh there
should be I thought maybe there would be
something yeah but there's not but he's
helping you in your new podcast yes yes
uh broad ideas yes broad ideas when I
looked at the subject matter of this
podcast with Olivia Allen yes who's now
an actress now going off to do a movie
Yes um she already got a movie she
decides to be an actress and she always
want to oh gosh don't talk to me about
what you can I can't say but she has
always wanted to act and she did a few
like small things when she was a lot
younger but now in her 40s she [__]
landed a movie I'm so proud of her good
for her yeah I know but this podcast I
saw that you guys talk about like what I
I like to talk about is mental health
yeah and how we deal with it and it
really helps people there's so many
people out there that that listen and
say this podcast really saves me or
helps me or and I'm like what what how
and it's just by hearing people like you
and and just like get personal if you do
and um but you are also talk about other
[__] like you know like ghosts and like
whatever which is which is cool I think
we kind of get into everything here
um I never perceived you as someone
that's like oh I bet that girl's really
open and talks I bet you weren't always
like that no no I definitely I put my
foot in my mouth many times since this
broadcast broadcast sure broad ideas
podcast it's a broadcast asked oh my God
that just dawned on me broadcast changed
the name damn it broadcast [__]
brilliant Rob came with a better idea
came up a better idea okay great I need
to summoned them he's gonna come I know
sorry uh yeah so I was I've always been
very private you know but there's
certain things and yes I've put my foot
in my mouth sometimes I'm joking around
sometimes you know we'll talk about
things that are pretty taboo and people
don't think it's appropriate to talk and
I'm a firm believer especially for women
in particular to have a safe space to
talk about all these I mean men too yeah
no but yeah both because there's so many
things that people feel like oh is this
weird or am I weird or or is this normal
and I think that it's just nice to be
able to relate to people on another
level absolutely I mean do you do you
get so you have you had anxiety like bad
anxiety in your life or depression or
have had to deal with any of that stuff
well for me I was never I never suffered
from like depression or anything but the
past few years you know the pandemic and
everything else and things in life uh it
was new for me so I've been dealing with
that now in my older age what is it
about that when we get older it's like I
never had this [__] you have it now well
I'm I uh I now it's better I've been
working on that yeah yeah and it's taken
a while but it's almost like my theory
is that when you're young your body can
take a lot you can go play football with
your friends and you rebound you can go
drinking with your friends and you
rebound and it's and it's easy because
you're young right and then the older
you get the more you stress when we get
older our bodies are like no [__] you oh
yeah [__] you I can't take this much
stress my knee has been saying [__] you
for a month to me because I fell skiing
so you know it's just you can't bounce
back and that's mentally too I think
that I think you're on to something yeah
but have you ever had a full-fledged
panic attack yeah but that's from like
weed or something or a drug my friend
Tommy's like that he's like we just
smoked pot and he goes he comes down the
stairs uh and he said he goes he's from
New Jersey and he said he literally
talks like this Ryan you talk like that
she's like
and he's sweating because Jesus Christ I
just like talk myself off a [__]
ledge I was just he sounds kind of like
Irish
I I guess I guess Joe's from New York or
whatever New Jersey he's like you're
[__] I just I [__] was looking at
my face in the mirror and I'm like
forget the [__] stop you're all right
you're not gonna die you're freaking out
yeah but we can sometimes do that to you
oh yeah absolutely I mean I I not you
like I'm good with weed like we have a
good relationship um and a very long one
but uh I yeah like it's if it's induced
and you get in your head but I have I
had more I've had more anxiety like in
my older age for sure yeah plus you have
a child I do have a child how old's the
child she's eight eight years old she's
awesome yeah if you hear an occasional
squeak it's my puppy I know you just got
a puppy Charlie yeah Charlie who you
said was a week old
but
um was I saying uh I have a daughter oh
yeah bad but you have a daughter but
like how look it's hard enough to have a
kid sure but then when you're
co-parenting yes so you're not obviously
married anymore you're divorced so
you're single and you're uh you know
you're you got work you get a podcast
you got you know auditions you got
whatever roles you're doing and you're
taking care of your daughter how do you
how do you do that I couldn't I could I
don't know if I could do that well you
don't even you don't have kids I I don't
have a child you have two dogs I have
two dogs as of now as of now do you want
kids I I don't think so I mean I don't
know I mean look at the woman I'm with
and I fall in love with her and she's
like I I don't know it feels right maybe
I'd consider but it's not like a big
thing for you that you've always known
you've wanted I think I did and I think
that time kind of has passed yeah it
doesn't really work that way so if you
notice that two times a week oh yeah I
know and it's not there can you well
I had braces and it took it away from me
my daughter's an excellent Whistler
really yeah I can't do that good for her
I know
um but the co-parently the co-parents
yeah it's just you know uh having a kid
definitely every day your life you're
like
okay my kid's alive you know seriously
no like you have these morbid thoughts
of like all the things that could happen
and that adds to the new found anxiety
that comes along with being older and
raising a kid and everybody like oh my
God like they could be crossing the
street you see all the the [__] news
like everything that they put out there
it's always the most horrendous story I
don't watch it anymore well yeah I don't
watch it but like on Instagram or
whatever it is it's all and it's all
like this person died because they were
walking across the street or like you
know and it's all of that so it just
keeps feeding your [__] mind with
this awful you know all these stories
I'm like where's the where are the
positive ones and it puts it in your
head so I'm constantly like oh [__] this
could happen and like there's nothing
more important in the world than your
child when you have one so it's just
becomes everything is way more
heightened because you're you have this
person that you're responsible for but
is it hard to just deal with the other
person and their schedules and they're
like you're not together anymore so is
it kind of weird have you gotten past
that yeah no we do really well well
that's good because a lot of people
don't right it's all it's all
circumstantial it's all different you
know situations and whatnot so we do
really well and my daughter knows
nothing but love and you know and that's
the most important thing you know yeah
so scheduling is whatever but you figure
it out you figure it out but she is so
loved by both of us and you know that's
all that's all you really need to do
that's the number one thing I always say
that it's just like you know I I you do
love scary movies sorry I was just
looking around it's just kind of a
little thing I don't always watch them
yeah I do but there's a lot there's a
lot of them yeah it's either
documentaries what's your favorite scary
movie I'm calling them scary movies I
mean probably I always say The Shining
it just sticks just directed like
everything that moves it's just that
they don't make them like that anymore
no but there's a lot of good ones if you
ever do you watch them sometimes it's
the only ones like I can stay awake for
at night okay well I have some that are
quality and I can give you a list that
you can avoid all the [__] that's out
there that Gets applauded By Rotten
Tomatoes which I have a thing for yeah
everything's 99 well yeah are they
getting paid well I mean I'm how could
you say this [__] is so good and you
watch it you're like yeah that was like
a 63. oh so you don't agree with rotten
I do not agree with Rotten Tomatoes I
think they get changed I think that
somebody pays them I think the Studios
have deals oh there's something there's
something going on I can see that yeah I
do I do yeah and it's like the big
critic the big critics and all that I
that's how I feel you think and I think
it's kind of skewed now because the
whole world is just in a different way
so like oh that person let's
let's give them a high score
without saying too much sure you know
what I'm saying yes I know you know what
I'm talking about Ryan
no no I don't think he did uh that's
okay
um you know I wanted to get into like
you know childhood because your mom was
a therapist so she's okay not a not a
behavioral therapist not a behavioral
therapist she doesn't have a degree you
know as a therapist but she has studied
her whole life and she counsels and she
specializes in Sex and you know all of
that stuff so she taught you about that
stuff oh my God but it's the opposite
for me all my friends want to know
everything from my mom and always have
but for me I'm like I don't wanna I
can't talk I don't want to talk to you
no I don't want it I don't wanna it's
like you know it's just this weird thing
but I can and I'll be like yeah Mom like
I totally like I had sex with this guy
like it's a very open relationship to
talk about all you tell your mom you had
sex with a guy yeah I mean I have does
she say did you use a condom
it's not old-fashioned like that no
she's like raw dog it girl yeah that's
my mom
no she's it's just nice that she's so
open but she she's way more into like
Tantra and like you know Tantra yeah
have you ever done Tantra no I haven't
either okay I feel like a lot of people
are interested in and they always want
to talk to my mom about it which is
great like talk to my mom I don't want
to think about my mom and my stepdad
like
disgusting I don't know why I feel the
tantra's like
um
they're just constantly having sex with
you
um I'm enjoying this yeah they're just
constantly you know chanting
um atheists think that it's like I think
the belief and what what it actually is
the philosophy behind it and all like
the internal stuff that can come along
with sex I think that's kind of the I
think it'd be interesting to learn about
yeah I I but I have not you have not not
really
all right it's my mom but your mom has
oh okay she shouldn't go there shouldn't
go there shouldn't go there she's
preaching it she is preaching it no and
I think it's great and I I love it good
for her are they still together not my
stepdad and my mom have been together a
long time right and my parents have been
divorced since I was nine how did that
affect you did it affect you at all I
think the first thing I said when they
told me they were getting divorced was I
get two Christmases
I don't know what that says about me but
wait weren't you Jewish yeah my dad's
Jewish but he loves Christmas so we
would always celebrate Christmas yeah we
did too we had a Christmas tree you did
because you're Jewish I'm Jewish yeah
yeah but you had a Christmas tree just
yeah you know that my grandma would come
down as Hanukkah claws in a red suit
they're not ringing the bell that's like
the that's like um
what is that it is ringing the bell from
money it is like chibi did it on Friends
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
better help it has been with me for a
long time and I think I know why because
this uh this podcast deals with a lot of
mental health
um people talking about their anxiety
and depressions and uh we're all
imperfect we're all flawed and that's
the beautiful thing about life and
sometimes we get in ruts sometimes
um our path isn't as clear that's in
front of us we're not sure what we're
going to do we can't find purpose this
is where better help comes in and it's
so important whether you're dealing with
decisions around your career your
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement trusting yourself to make
decisions that align with your values is
like anything the more you practice it
the easier it gets the great thing about
this is the stigma is going away folks
so you know my dad he doesn't go to
therapy and you know I've been talking
to him I'm like listen everybody so many
people do this you're not the only
person who gets in ruts you know when we
lost my sister
um I finally got him into therapy and um
it's just important to know you're not
alone you're just not alone and with
better help you can get your therapist
online if you don't like your therapist
you change it like that it's so easy
it's so much more affordable than
looking up some therapist that you don't
know and going uh yeah and it costs you
so much money to go in there look if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
it's convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire it's so so quick and get
matched with a licensed therapist switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge period it's entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire it takes seconds and get
matched with a licensed therapist switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge let therapy be your map with
better help visit betterhelp.com inside
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better or help help.com inside
let therapy be your map with better help
visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's ten percent
off your first month better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
but you you had a pretty
good childhood I think I don't know I
think you don't know I could tell you I
didn't okay that's how easy I could say
I didn't you didn't no why well I you
don't want to hear my story I can tell
you some other time but like you know
just a lot of dysfunction a lot of uh
you know Ryan's heard it a million times
[__] up on a scale from one to ten
hundred fifty times how [__] up on a
scale from one to ten I don't know I
don't wanna do that from what you've
heard I mean it didn't sound great but
you turned out okay I mean you're able
to talk about it and uh yeah you had a
Hanukkah Clause yeah you did have a
Hanukkah look you know the the tough
thing for me was my dad used to oh I'm
not a good parent I don't put a roof
over your head I don't give you a hot
meal every night I'm like one of my uh
slave that's hard so you had the kind of
like a dominant uh Alpha dad of sorts
it's just let's just say this uh
my brother wrote something about the
family of what he remember he woke up
woke up with a nightmare and he wrote
stuff down and when he got to me he read
it to me he said and when we got to and
then there was Michael
and nobody paid any attention to him at
all
and I go you know what happened sums it
up and I remember I I kind of cried a
little not a hard cry yeah but I didn't
cry to him but I didn't cry because I
didn't pay attention to me I cried
because someone acknowledged that yeah
so but you were seen for the first time
I was seen yeah
oh yeah I'm here all day all right no
I'm here for an hour but no but it's you
know it's uh so that's why I say I I
know you know was my was it the worst no
no those are some good moments sure but
but yes always in therapy and really
worked on myself like good so much
better than I was because I acknowledged
the reasons why I do that I go oh
that's like this is why you're doing
that stop that stop you know yeah do you
do that you find yourself doing that or
yeah I mean I think that also falls into
like taking accountability and like all
of that and even for your own actions
and looking at yourself with all that
[__] it's it's it's
therapy is the best thing you can do I
think and I was in therapy for the past
few years and my therapist retired and
I've been having a really hard time
figuring out like where to go and like
it's like starting all over again you
know and it's like oh [__] I gotta start
from the beginning like this whole story
again that you know that and I I hear I
hear you yeah I hear you it's like when
you want to change therapists and just
they have to hear everything you've
talked about so you've built this
relationship with this other person but
the reality is once you go to that first
one
and you talk the first time you're like
okay a lot of that was out second time
through okay now he kind of gets me now
we can move on so it does move faster it
seems overwhelming and daunting but I I
think it you know you're thinking of
getting another therapist oh yeah I need
to what makes you like what things do
you do that you notice like you need to
see therapists you lash out yes scream
I'm [__] I'm a real punching walls
what do you do no I you know I just I I
think there's like
I've experienced like certain traumas
like as I've gotten older right and I've
noticed that my body like because your
muscles store this trauma and I've
noticed that my body can go into
the trauma right if I'm if I'm triggered
by something whatever it may be and so
for me I'm like oh [__] like I need to
work on this to figure out how to get
through this and pass this trauma so I
literally don't physically react like
I'll I won't be able to like eat and
I'll be like hunched over and I'll be
like in pain like nauseous I'm like why
can't I just talk myself out of this and
I really do believe that it is because
your muscles store this memory
and so your memory is like the trauma
everything oh it's connected to
everything right right yeah and so and
it might not have anything to do with
what the trauma was about but it's it's
probably has something to do with what
the trauma is about but and it just
brings that out and that's the hardest
thing and so I've heard a lot about
is it EMDR yeah I did it you did it I
was gonna say it how was it
mind-boggling like in a good way I went
in and I've always heard the story like
once right
I mean 280 episodes like I [__]
insane
thank you Ryan [__] you man
um so I
I went to this place because I just
needed to clear my head my friend Zach
Levi went there he was there and he was
like he's like I think you should go
there and I go all right fine expensive
but I was like you know thank God I
could afford it I'm gonna go
and there were
one of the uh classes one of the uh
therapists was an EMDR specialist and I
went in there and uh we did like
sessions and they go look I don't even
know if I'm right candidate for this I'm
already doubting myself trying I gotta
be great in this EMDR session she goes
We're not gonna do that today like okay
and we talked and then the next session
we're going going she goes oh and we're
not going to do it today and I go okay
and at the end of that session she asked
me something and I mentioned something
about my childhood jokingly
I go oh yeah and then and then this
happened it was just like you're stupid
and you know and Farley and then I do
that every once in a while and then and
then the therapist goes she she goes
I think we're ready to do this I go uh
why don't we get like 10 minutes left
and then she goes no all right do you
want to do this now I I think we should
do like oh okay don't do anything
I want you to close your eyes
I want you to close your eyes and I want
you to think of that moment I want you
to think around your surround about your
surroundings what you were doing the
feeling you had and I wanted and I
started to think about that and really
go there and she goes then I want you to
open your eyes and follow my finger and
I kept doing it doing it I'm like this
is bananas what the [__] but I stay with
it I said I'm here for a reason and I
and she goes okay close your eyes she's
what do you see and I said blah blah
blah blah blah the second time I opened
my eyes
hysterical crime crime it came out of
nowhere where I wasn't even trying tears
were just flowing I'm like whoa I can't
do this with acting you know and uh it
went on and on and on for about 20
minutes
and then I opened my eyes and she said
and it was kind of uh there was a
through line there was sort of the whole
thing you know it started here emotional
emotional motion build build and then by
the end I just
therapist said well what are you
thinking and I go
and all that came to me was
I forgive them oh wow
I forgive them and I was crying and I
was like
they didn't they did the best that they
could do and it was not good and I
didn't deserve it and whatever
and it was so cathartic
and she says what it does is it's like a
big tree in the forest that one big tree
you just knocked down so now with the
MDR when you think about that because I
would think about that story a lot and
if I did bother I mean obviously
subconsciously bothered yeah it was just
in there and
I don't think about it anymore and if I
do if I try to think of it it doesn't
affect me wow and that big tree also
knocks down some little trees too so it
helps with other things but the more you
do it
the better so right I recommend it so
when you say trauma you don't have to go
into it but like like what kind of
trauma or do you not want to talk about
I mean it'll probably bring it up if I
talk no just just things I've
experienced you know did you say you'll
probably bring it up if I don't talk
about it if I talk about it like
relationship stuff
some relationship stuff yeah for sure
you know
um
just just [__] life just life that
happens you know you get older and
there's so many experiences that you go
through not all are going to be great
you know some are gonna maybe leave a
mark more than others
um but yeah it's just like oh [__] like
you're older and you're like uh like for
instance I I remember this is relating
it to like work like I was up for a
movie and the character had been through
so much and was pregnant whatever and I
lost the role to like a 20 something who
had I didn't have any of these
experiences and I'm like
so much has come from all these life
experiences that I've had that I
actually have a better understanding of
how to bring it into my work and I'm not
like a smackery type at all you know you
let things go but this one yeah and it
was like well no not even that I just
mean schmattering in the way of like I'm
gonna be method and I'm gonna like you
know like you
like I have fun and I just go for it and
I'd stay in the moment and I have a
whole other whatever right but yeah but
in this instance I was like huh I'm
older and I've learned so much I can
actually use this now which
you can't when you're 21 I'm sorry like
it's just absolutely you know it's life
it's an experience that's why the older
you get the better if you love The Craft
the art you're gonna get better right as
an actor sure the more mature the more
life you have right you know you can
bring it to a role you know yeah and I
yeah I certainly do that I think that's
why I was able to do it because I would
definitely Channel certain things I
could go [__] dark right easily well
yeah you were like a bad guy right oh
yeah I mean that yeah but like yeah some
of those moments man where I went
[__] bananas dude I'm telling you
when you say method I'm not I'm saying I
lost myself
sometimes and I was like
whoa whoa yeah it just you get I mean it
felt great
but when you're not
doing that thing but it's from
experiences and that's I think a lot of
you know they always say comedians are
really damaged yes most of them are and
they are right because there has to be
some Darkness you know to bring that
humor because it overcompensates and
yeah and they're brilliant and they're
[__] hilarious but there has to be
Darkness there I feel like there are
some that don't have it maybe they're
not as funny I don't know yeah maybe not
on that maybe Seinfeld maybe so no I had
a great one I mean everything was fine
oh my parents they took me to Yeshiva I
was Bar Mitzvah I made some money I had
a fine childhood you had it fine I
wonder if Larry had it fine Larry no he
was he was just it was just neurotic yes
there were so much so much craziness
going on probably in this house like
mine you know my mom's just off the wall
oh she's like on valium doing imaginary
snow angels in the carpet oh yeah she
was like she was having a good time she
would come in the room and we'll
actually met she goes
[Music]
she leaves and Stomps up the stairs in
her nightgown at like four four p.m and
my dad's like Jesus Christ
and I kind of looked at my girl
I mean it was [__] like that all the
time I just remember my dad when he was
there was that moment before he's going
to give you a smack you go
when you saw that you know he's gonna
literally Lurch out at you oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we didn't have like
spanking in my house no spanking no no
it sounds like your mom did maybe with
all that sex I'm just kidding get out of
here
by the way you're you're kind of
accident prone aren't you yeah well how
do you know that well because you got in
a horrible car crash does that make me
accident was it your fault no okay then
you're right accident
I got in a car it wasn't my fault how
does that mean the accident well you
were you were there you're prone to get
an accidents
I was 14 in the back seat but you know
what that makes me accident Pro no like
tripping and fall like sure oh you do
that yeah but I was in a horrific car
accident when I was 14. yeah because Rob
told me that it was pretty traumatic
yeah Rob told you about my car accident
or you asked I asked oh okay I was like
that's really random yeah yeah as I said
you know is there you know anything
[__] like really bad that happened in
her life we can talk about
this message is sponsored by discover
did you know you could reduce the number
of unwanted calls and emails with online
privacy protection the latest Innovation
from discover discover will help
regularly remove your personal info like
your name and address from 10 popular
people search websites that could sell
your data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection no but but it was
traumatic right yeah yeah yeah for sure
well I say that but like I had a head
injury so I don't remember I remember
everything up until the point
that uh the accident happened so I black
out I have no memory of the actual
accident
um helicopter to the hospital jaws of
life like all the goodies you almost
died yeah I think so I think like I lost
you know the signs for a few minutes
um you went Code Blue I don't maybe yeah
I don't know Flatline for a second maybe
or two I I have the police report
you say maybe on all these things again
if I got in a horrible car accident and
I was pronounced dead I would remember
these things I wasn't pronounced dead I
mean I feel like that would have been a
big you know
it's a big thing right I'm sorry for
laughing are you kidding I have the best
sense of humor about everything I'll
continue yes [__] car accidents are
[__] hilarious yeah I was in a car
accident it was crazy but how bad no no
I didn't nothing really happened
um we were just lucky we were like yeah
we were going to Depeche Mode concert
nice on the way back home 1991 violator
tour I never wanted was here in my arms
and we're going and Rick Camacho's tires
were bald and it's raining and he's just
going around like you know cars are
coming this way we're going
and it just hydroplane kept going into
their Lane and I saw this truck coming
oh no and I go oh my God I grabbed my
pillow and I went behind Jacobs Jacob
was in the passenger seat and I just I
remember it took forever here I was like
oh oh God
oh and all of a sudden it was just
silence oh that's and I looked over and
Jacob had like blood on his head no and
Rick was like oh my God oh my God and
the car was smashed right up to their
legs like right another half of three
inches and their legs would have been
gone oh my God and it was it was true
see remember I remember that because
nothing I remember exactly what happened
because I was I didn't pass out but you
lost Consciousness were helicoptered out
were you losing a lot of blood I don't
know or maybe internal organs it was
like I think part of my head was like
kind of scalped a little bit like I have
a scar but it's weird it stops like
right here at my hairline so you can't
see it but it was like yeah like you
know black eye scalped up here uh I
think I was in a coma for like a little
tiny bit were you with your parents no
no no no no no no no no no I was with my
friends my friend who was driving who
was 16 and we were dating these guys
that were older they were not good guys
and um partying on the beach you know
Strawberry Hill if you're familiar oh
yeah yeah Boons oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
come on now I'm gonna have a little
Bartles and James yeah you know of
course you don't know [__]
two young these youngins yeah so like we
were all kind of partying it was in
Oxnard and we were driving in the and
the dude in the passenger seat that was
my friend's whatever was turned around
on his knees tickling the guy I was with
who was like laying on me in the back
seat
and at one point he just got his hand
and he Yanks the steering wheel the guy
in the passenger seat we're on PCH going
you know pretty fast and he just yanked
the wheel and we went over into oncoming
traffic and we were in a little Ford
Probe which is I don't know if they make
him anymore they're really small and we
hit like a big truck
uh maybe it was even like did anyone die
Chuck no if one guy is paralyzed
um god the guy with me is mentally not
well I don't think and uh I think he's
in jail for murder maybe I shouldn't say
that I don't know
um yeah but anyway it was very gnarly oh
my God black out was your friend okay
yeah like her foot was kind of like
hanging off or something but she was
okay and this is really uplifting story
yeah the last image I have is his hand
on the steering wheel and then that's
all I remember why what do you've done
that they were on drugs
oh maybe speed I forgot definitely not
Strawberry Hill definitely not yeah no
definitely not just that so you probably
had to did you go through therapy with
that stuff about Rehabilitation or well
no like we were in the hospital and like
I said like it was a head injury so I
don't I always wonder though if at some
point is it just gonna come back to me
like and that's a little terrifying like
is that just gonna like sometime just
pop up I wonder if the EMDR I guaranteed
it would why then I don't want to do it
well no if you if you you choose the
incident you choose the trauma oh okay
you don't need to revisit that truck no
no it sounds like you do not I'm good
with it you don't need to go back
yourself
I want to go back to this time where I
almost died does it affect you no why do
you want to go back there right I just
do you know it's kind of [__] you
don't want to do it no I don't want to
do that not interested but I'm glad
you're alive I am too I am I am too I'm
14 and it really changed things for me
you know I was hanging out probably with
not with the wrong crowd yeah and uh it
kind of set me on a different trajectory
so great thank god oh yeah yeah I was
brutal like I now that I'm a parent
imagining like my parents getting that
call that they're 14 year old you know
in that massive of a car accident
I don't even that's awful for some
reason it reminds me of the Murdoch why
did you see the documentary wait what no
remind me is it the murder boating
accident oh it's a boating and the guy
was really drunk and he shouldn't have
been driving and they told him not to
and he was like this kid he's probably
14 15. and he's driving the boat and
they're drinking beer and then he
smashes into this bridge and it kills
one of the girls and you know his dad's
the biggest lawyer in the town and
everybody's scared of him and he says he
comes into the hospital right after all
the kids are in the hospital he goes in
there he's like you're not going to
mention who was driving the boat nobody
mentioned who's driving the boat and
then uh then he starts to pin it it's if
you've seen the documentary well he pins
it on someone else he tries to just oh
my God this is a Netflix documentary
that will blow oh my God okay you have
to watch it I'm gonna watch it it's
fantastic so so yeah you've had some
trauma in your life again you know I
think that makes her a better person
you're sort of like hey I've been there
I've done that I've had this in my life
and look I'm still here I'm still doing
do you do you still love acting
did I ever love act no I don't know in
all fairness I loved like when I wanted
to get into it I was in the drama
program in high school I loved it loved
it the plays everything I've loved
everything I've done like the shows I'm
so grateful for them
I don't love the business
I you know
I think I am so blessed that I get to do
that and I've I it's such a weird
question I know what you're saying it's
like you're grateful you're so
appreciative for everything it you've
res you've gotten you've received you've
worked hard for all that I do love it I
love when I get to do it and I get to
work not everything to you now no I mean
I have a kid that's everything to me
things change I'm the type of person I
am Mom first always no matter what I put
that above everything else I've passed
on things because my kids the most
important thing in the world I love it
yeah so that's why I'm like well yeah I
love it and I love doing it and when I
can do it it's awesome it's so much fun
and I'm so lucky I get to do it right
but my mom is everything I I just I
think something happened with me too
where I just
like five years ago I did a series and
then after it I just sort of
was like ah I just I don't know if I
love it maybe I just need a break then I
took a break and then it got a lot
longer break then I did a little thing
and then a little thing I was like yeah
I don't know 14 hours a day fun well
right because there's that side of it
and you don't want to ever sound like
you're complaint no I just you know but
like and then once I'm a mom and I went
back to work when she was three years
old and I was on like a two-hander and
in every scene and I'm like oh my God
how can I do this because you are
sometimes 16 18 hour days you know
there's a lot of other things that go
into it which it's harder on your
personal life and if you have a kid
um and I always joke I'm like oh you
know I always dated co-stars because
you're not gonna see anybody else
it's true
actors date actors you're like well
because we're unsettled it's the only
people we meet right and then we're like
all right how many co-stars do you think
you've dated in your life well I don't
know would you say A3 B7 C more than
seven I would say d all of them no I'm
just kidding
um I have had two public relationships
that were co-stars right everybody knows
that do they
well one you had a kid with oh yeah I
guess that gives that one away jumper
which is a great movie I don't think
that was so much oh that's great when
you love jumper I never saw it what
you're a [__] this is the last God why
would you say Star Wars though
have you ever had situations where
you're dating your Coast car and it's
just not going well on set now it's just
a weird vibe and you're like [__] I
don't you know I obviously Adam Brody
and I dated on the OC and we broke up
like right before the end of the show oh
perfect yeah you know the timing was
everything and we had to do the last I
want to say a couple months Maybe
but we got along really well
um and I would say it was the best maybe
it wasn't even a couple months maybe it
was a couple weeks but it was like the
best version of it because I'm sure it
could go around South yes yeah I'm sure
I hear that
um yeah it's just I I've never I I did
that in Germany once I was doing this
movie that no one will ever see
um don't ask me I was gonna say oh what
is it it doesn't matter don't you even I
know you know what it is yeah no no it's
it's don't even get what is it Ryan Rave
Macbeth okay it was a movie that looked
it was it should have been good but then
we had to dub the entire movie they lost
the audio and now it's just a joke they
lost to the audience yeah it was all
gone I had the loop I was the lead I had
to do every line and it ruined I was in
there going because I had an obligation
I was like I don't want to [__] be
here I just I can't believe I'm doing
everyone in my performance I'm emotional
and screaming and drug induced and like
I'm going oh
[__] you oh my God that's brutal but
anyway I I was right away I we were my
co-star and I were really attracted to
uh each other her name was Nikki acock
she passed just passed away what yeah
she just passed away it shocked me I
believe it was leukemia oh my God I
hadn't been in touch with her for years
but I I adored her she was so sweet we
got along so well and you know what we
it happened and then we kind of were
like you know I'm like hey I'm my 20s
and I'm like you know you know and you
know we started but it ended up working
okay but it could have been a disaster
it could have been a disaster but we
were both cool about it that's good yeah
so I just hope they're cool people yeah
it's uh I mean do you have sort of a a
propensity for going out with actors
um what does that mean uh you know just
like is this do you does it have to be
an actor or a producer or someone in the
business no it doesn't no
look no it does not God damn it uh no of
course not there is the thing that like
they understand like what exactly you do
yeah you know and they get it but and
look yes my track record they're you
know I have dated actors
um you know what's funny I haven't you
haven't I don't know I haven't ever I
mean yeah no that's not true I have
forget it I have I just thought about it
I was like yeah you do no yeah but not a
long term or a lot
oh long term no okay uh we're gonna get
going it's you oh okay baby it's you
I've been waiting for remember the song
all of my life yeah all of them Stephen
Bishop sure how old are you 41. are you
really yes
get lost okay bye 41 when's your
birthday August August so you're a Leo
no I'm a Virgo I'm at the end oh I don't
know anything about Virgos okay anyway
moving on um all right so yes I
understand the whole world they
understand your schedules and all that
but um and especially yeah yeah but
every time it's like oh I'm not gonna
date another actor you know but you just
do the people you surround yourself with
I think director like I love that aspect
and and they understand it as well but
it's really just about people and people
you meet and if you like Vibe well
whatever that's all it's about you're
right it's just the People You Meet more
you you're at work a lot of the time and
so those are the people you spend your
time with that's all that's all that it
is
I know you went to Notre Dame I did High
School yes and you you went to school
with you know Remy Malik who I think
went to U of e yeah he went to where I
grew up in Evansville Indiana yes he did
yeah he went there yes I tried to get
him on the podcast he hasn't returned my
call uh I said hey we're both Evans
Kirsten Dunst
uh Catherine McPhee do you talk to any
of those girls women I see them okay so
you're not cool you're never close no
like not super close we were friends in
high school for sure Romney and I were
the out of those day Romy and I were the
closest yeah um oh yeah and uh
yeah because we we were in the same
friend group we were in drama together
actually Kirsten and um cat were in
drama as well at the same time I mean
Kirsten was already working and like off
shooting things and stuff so she wasn't
always there
um but they were always so nice and Kat
was like the cutest thing ever and had
the most amazing voice and so cool to
see everything they've done I mean
Robbie's done all right you know I mean
did he win an Oscar yeah he did he won
the Oscar he was always
[__] amazing like even in high school
in the plays like we would do the plays
together we did The Crucible together
he's
an incredible actor do you think um
the OC will ever have a movie
a movie yeah because they're doing
movies with all these shows I feel like
it could be like a limited
I'm gonna throw that out there
yeah of course like OC like Josh
Schwartz is my family like yeah he cast
you in another thing a couple things
yeah but we're also like he's one of my
best friends he's like my brother yeah
we're so close I would and Stephanie
Savage as well like I always say I would
do anything they would just be like you
want to do this it doesn't matter what
it is it'd be like okay yeah when do I
wear where do I go
um but my pitch is a limited series
let's do eight maybe ten probably eight
episodes
and called her day would everybody come
back you think I'm trying to we're
trying to like break some people down to
see oh so you're already in on this no I
mean no you are no we have we have a few
hard no's so it's not gonna happen
probably but you won't even tell me the
hard nose well yeah I mean if you Google
it I'm sure the hard nose were there to
be right the hard nose are there I love
that you did commercials for like
Pepto-Bismol they should have had me do
that because you need it often maybe I
remember the commercial
you like farts
um do I like them I mean are you cool
okay how do you feel about that in
relationships open farting
um I I don't know I don't I don't think
I I don't know I think it would kind of
I don't know yeah no I don't I don't
like it yeah because it makes it much
more attractive yeah no like you hide
that [__] yeah but if an occasional like
blast comes from the office that's kind
of funny but like just keep it out of
the bedroom keep it out you know I don't
want to roll you into an enchilada and
like blast you know
yeah I just think that you know I'm not
I don't ever I don't like sharing that
stuff no you're uh you're a close the
door leave me alone uh up yeah did you
disappear you're one of those women who
disappear and like where'd they go they
must be pooping in the third bathroom on
the third floor right no but we talk
about this a lot on bright ideas it's
like when you go away on a trip with
someone for the first time right
how are you gonna how is that gonna work
out that's the biggest concern Where Are
You Gonna [__] I know what you do what
do you do here's what I would do what
would you do I'd probably say hey the
pool looks really sweet why don't you
head out to the pool I gotta take care
of a few things interesting or you say
hey I'm gonna go check with the front
desk I'll be back I want to see if they
have any massages and then
and then you know come back and go
you're like what about the massages like
oh they weren't there and just what if
they want to go with you see that no no
no no no you say you you stay there I
want to take care of this I want to
surprise you well it's not a surprise
anymore you already told me I know but I
just wanted something I have to do on my
own all right I gotta take a [__]
it's a thing man it's a thing all right
this is called [__] talking with Rachel
Bilson this is rapid fire these are my
top tier patrons ask questions uh
patreon.com inside of you I love you
guys they support the show more than
awesome it just clarify it's different
from the segment we were just doing on
[__] oh yeah
yeah you're very easy to talk to well
thanks I mean it's really easy is it not
normal well sometimes it's like pointing
I mean I know I mean we had one um
the other day that was just like
[Laughter]
right okay so yeah it was just no no we
always have like questions to fall back
on if need be yeah I don't know an
Arsenal
um Leanne says who has been the one
person that always believed in you and
have you ever paid it forward ah you
know I would say my mom because that's
the obvious answer but I'm gonna give
credit to my best friends Olivia and
Leah because they have got me through
everything and they're my lifelines and
now Olivia my co-host and Leah sometimes
fills in and she's off doing a movie so
and your dad also said if this is true
what you should go in acting my dad saw
me do the play I did with Romney and he
was like you know what you're kind of
kind of actually good at this do you
want to like do it and I was like yeah
yeah I do and then that's all right so
he was sort of there he was sort of
there literally so what's the worst job
you've ever had well I had one I can't
say that I had a job I wouldn't say it
was the worst job okay sorry I was a
hostess at Sicily this restaurant in the
valley for a short time but I my first
job I ever got was for A Raisin Bran
Crunch commercial and I had to dance for
12 hours and you only saw my butt in the
commercial
and after I had to like I couldn't I
couldn't move I was very I'm not a
dancer you know that day that day was
horrible no it was good but then after
it was bad
in other words you're in pain yes
yes okay that makes sense
my worst job you know I got fired from
McDonald's for what for taking you know
that how at the end of this at the end
of the it's closing McDonald's does
close and I was just taking
some leftover uh McRibs
that works I've never heard anyone like
I love McRibs I've never tried them
there were like six left and I'm like
we're close I'm like I'm putting this in
a bag I'm gonna bring him but my dad was
picking me up and I went out there and
the guy the manager goes Michael what's
in the back
what's in the box
I go John Doe knows the Outback John
Doe's got the other hand don't look in
the box
um I go oh it's just uh old McRibs and
he goes what's the policy
um I don't know they were going to go in
the trash
come here please
and we went and it was my third write-up
because I didn't mop the floor in Arches
what I swear on my on my family's life
they made me mop the floor dip
ring
arches dip I'm not kidding oh my God I
got written up for that I got written up
for saying something to a customer like
uh it's like I'll have the uh for uh
probably Fry's not worth it today or
something
they're like what do you mean I was like
yeah I'm just I'm looking for it they're
like what are you doing what do you like
[__]
zaggets
I mean all right little uh Julie church
that's Julie with one eye were you on
board with the direction the OC took
after one of the most iconic character
deaths in teen drama
was I on board with it
I mean that's a question yeah we got we
got Che also known as Chris Pratt well I
got to go to Brown no it was you know I
just watched the whole series back
um for this rewatch podcast and uh
it's really hard when Marissa dies I
mean I couldn't watch it forever Misha
and I wound up watching it together
like uh during an interview for the
podcast and
I realized like oh man it was a bummer
when she left but the fourth season
it kind of it's kind of like we everyone
was just having fun and it was funny and
a lot lighter once you got through The
Grieving stuff that I really enjoyed
where they went with it and the OC
podcast is coming to an end if you're
having Ben McKenzie on the podcast yeah
that's right that's exciting so listen
to and it's called Welcome to the OC
[__] right and the new podcast
brought ideas which should have been
broadcast damn it you know what I'm
still gonna use it we're gonna put that
in why don't you do a little segment
this is called broadcast yeah okay we're
gonna answer questions from this yep I
like it
uh Sophie
um quickly God can you tell us any
audition or set stories from your time
on Nashville playing Alyssa green
any stories I don't know
I don't know
what I I so I played I had you know a
few episodes I forget how many I did and
I was going on Nashville but my
character was like I want to say she was
a lawyer maybe she wasn't she was
something that wasn't an entertainer
right and I said well I'm going on
Nashville I have to sing so they
literally found a way to write in where
I got to sing a song which is so weird
and random are you nervous
I was I was I wasn't I was nervous but
it wasn't as nervous because you go in
and you record it before and then you're
just on set so that went great okay but
there's amazing singers on that show so
I was like oh here I am like carrying a
tune
um but it was fun Super Sam the OC dealt
with a lot of big topics for teenagers
and never seemed to shy away from
anything that was too real do you have a
favorite storyline or topic they tackled
um I think I like a lot of things they
tackled I just love Olivia Wilde so much
so when they did the whole
um uh story with Marissa and Alex
I thought that was cool and like it
wasn't you know it was a big thing
because it like Fox like had a thing
where like you can't show them kissing
too much or whatever which is a bummer
and I wish if they could redo it now you
know they could do a little more with it
because it was a great storyline this
has been a real good time yeah this was
great I'm happy it worked out finally
yeah I know you weren't easy it wasn't
easy no I mean scheduling yeah
podcast anything else coming up just the
new podcast the new yes so broad ideas
yes and when does it come out broadcast
now it's out it's out well you know
will you come on come on we've had
really good people I I would love to
come on it be hilarious you should look
up you can ask me anything oh I will
oh you can broadcast you'll be the first
broadcast segment
There You Go full circle do you want do
you want your daughter to be an actor no
but she's already like shows all the
signs like what she's so
animated and Mom she performs and
exaggerates and like if she's reading a
book with exclamation she's like
but what do you mean Timmy like it's
like full on she has it in her I mean
both of her parents you know
actors no we are actors do you think
he'll ever get married again I was never
married I've never been married do you
think he'll ever get married
I don't know what I mean is this
something you have a kid I do everything
usually people get married to have a
child children to have a children to
have a children I have a child I do have
a children and I think that I you know
yeah like that stuff the legal stuff
it's like do I do we need to deal with
that of course I've always I love
clothes like I would love to pick out a
dress but like I don't need to get
married you know I wear dresses you know
why not like you know I guess in
everybody's mind you're always you
proverbial you is always thinking you
know it'd be nice to have everybody
there and then you know I think my
friends would be like wow he actually
did it he actually oh my God or like
this is and it's just like hey I found
my person and you know hey we're not you
know I mean it's just like what else is
there you don't you don't get with
somebody to get married you you're with
them and then when there's nothing else
you're like oh you want to get married
I don't want that much I've always said
I do not want to walk down an aisle and
everyone looking at me that makes me
very uncomfortable yeah it makes sense
that I'm an actor I know they would
probably look at you if we walk down the
aisle it's eyes on you what I'm saying
is like I would never I just don't I
don't like that much attention I don't
like being the center of attention
really yeah never happened you always
like the you know the person you're with
let them be the center of attention
yeah
I tend to be but I I don't know I mean I
was always performing so maybe I I don't
want to be looked at at a wedding all
right fine if I just
invite no one I'm gonna wear a sheet
where's sheet that's how the Jews do it
that's right they do it that's right
they sure do they do all about it um all
right this has been awesome thanks for
coming on thanks for having me this was
fun
thank you Rachel for joining us I
appreciate that
um but totally marry her
she's uh
you know she's just she's a woman she's
she's she she knows her [__] yeah she
has her [__] together as far as I know
she has her [__] together I mean we see
what we see but we don't always know
no I mean she appears to be out in the
world doing things yes and doing a good
job of them and being uh
she's confident what she's doing yes and
talented and and well regarded and uh at
home and at work yes
she has children um
yes that's no easy feat that's no easy
I'm complaining about my dog
doesn't it you don't have to I mean your
dog's pissing and [__] and everywhere
just think about the kids yeah changing
those diapers every well I don't think
they're that young anymore
uh if he didn't listen to oh I'm not
going to repeat it but uh the anxiety
podcast inside you online store and all
that other Jazz just rewind and you get
all the information where I'm going to
be where I'm going all that are you
doing anything you've been traveling a
lot Ryan I have been yeah I've been been
all over
my sister's wedding and uh Bob and
everywhere band uh yeah I'm going back
up north see my parents again my aunt's
getting married oh nice uh
my mom's sister is getting married
uh a lot of people getting married your
sister got married getting married
um
it's a lot going it's a lot oh yeah oh
then yeah then I have a friend in L.A
getting married in September and we're
going this bachelor party is gonna be in
August Hey Ron guess what what I'm not
getting married no here are the shout
out to patreon.com inside of you
couldn't do it without you and I I thank
you I wish I could read each person's
name a hundred times
um a lot of these people have been with
me from the beginning I mean from the
beginning of patreon when I started
doing it and they've stuck with me and
sometimes I get a little
you know worried I'm like are they
liking their my the box that I send them
are they liking the the notes and it's
it's a lot of stress but um I hope you
guys are digging that I hope you know I
really personalize each note and take
the time and
um you know Joe and I packed the boxes I
tell them what to put in there and uh
it's hard my house is full of merch and
uh I every time I want to get new merch
I have no room to put it
you got your own merch and you got um
merch that you bought yeah I got also
you got yeah you just get there's a lot
of merch there's always no merch there's
new merch
um here are the shout outs here are the
names the lovely people Nancy D and by
the way thank you for messages that you
sent
um whether I read it on Google mail or
in the inside of you podcast
um sort of uh email base where people
chime in
um and also if you order something from
the inside of you online store make sure
you there's a message where you could
say please do this because sometimes I
sign something oh I don't want it signed
to me I'm like how was I supposed to
know that and then they want to refund
and I'm like God I'm just sending so
much stuff back and I don't know how to
fix it I'm just like write a message
it's going to be Auto either just my
signature Maybe
but you know there's some things they
want personalized which I always
personalize them and you know there's a
message thing where you can message on
the thing anyway I'm not going to talk
okay anymore Nancy D Leah asks and
Kristen k little Lisa Yukiko Jill e
Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie M
Rashi Joshua D Jennifer Ann Stacy L
Jamal F Janelle B Mikey L down soprano
99 more Santiago M correct Chad W lien P
Maddie s Belinda and correct Dave Dave
hole I love Dave hole every time I'll
get to Dave home hey Michael
I really enjoyed your podcast
um but you're an [__] for trying to
do my voice in our soul I love Dave I've
said that a million times I hope you
love me Dave Sheila G Brad d Ray
correct Tabitha tea Tom and Talia and
Betsy D correct Angel M Rhiannon C Cory
K Dev Jackson Michelle a Jeremy
Irons C Brandy D yavor Joey M Eugene and
Leia Corey Jake B Angela F Mel s
Christine s Eric H Shane R correct
Andrew ml Amanda
[Music]
yes gen B Kevin e Stephanie K Jarrell
Jammin J and Leanne p no f c no if I
said Lee jam and J and Leanne Jay
correct Luna R Mike F Stone
Gossard no remember how we remember
Stone
the famous wonders of the world
Henge Stone Age Brian L Kendall L
Meredith I Kara C Jessica B Kyle F
Marisol
yes Estevan
G yes Kaylee J Brian a Ashley F Marion
Louise L Romeo B Veronica Q Frank B
Genty Nikki L April R Cassie B and Derek
n thank you newcomers who have joined
patreon and support us we love you and
uh there's not much I could say other
than thanks for listening again
and we're on strike here the SAG you
know so right now thank God I had a lot
of these pre-recorded oh yeah before the
strike yeah and it's going to be hard to
get guests I'm thinking but you know as
long as they can't they just can't talk
about future projects I don't remember
the last time these are so far in the
can yeah so yeah they're in the can
thank God I did that right there were so
many there was I was going to do more
too and I was like I can't at one point
we had 20. we had 20. because I knew you
were leaving town I was leaving town but
I didn't know there was going to be a
strike and so we're good for a little
while yeah but um I'm gonna have to
start getting guests here in about a
month so we're good for now
um thank you for listening
thank you for watching I'm sorry I
didn't shower this morning Ryan did you
shower I did you look like you showered
well because you said can you come over
now and I said yeah I'm gonna shower you
said you were naked you're getting some
clothes that was still in my jammies do
you wear pajamas just like it's a
t-shirt that I was like did you just
walk around your underwear no what do
you walk around in it was just a T-shirt
and sweat shorts okay you're not an
underwear walking around guy no
I'm Michael Rosenbaum from the Hollywood
Hills in California I'm Brian Tales from
the same place
a little wave of the camera we love you
guys and uh be good to yourself
foreign